à la rentrée interview oui ça faisait
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas entendu
parler de greta sur son compte twitter
la jeune militante écologiste greta
tomberg vient d'annoncer son retour sur
les bancs de l'école
mon indice à batik est terminée que
c'est bon de retourner à l'école
l'année scolaire précédente elle avait
décidé de prendre une petite année
sabbatique pour défendre la cause du
climat aux quatre coins de la planète
et depuis lundi elle est entrée au lycée
avec le co vide le confinement l'avait
presque oublié pense quand même une
pointure en 2018 alors qu'elle a 15 ans
elle se fait connaître en organisant les
grèves de l'école pour le climat d'abord
en suède puis partout dans le monde est
fait boule de neige direct manif partout
dans le monde
greta s'adresse à la coop 24 le 4
décembre 2018 et quelques mois plus tard
devant le parlement britannique et
l'assemblée nationale
et c'est à l'été 2010 neuf qu'elle
commence son petit tour du monde
[Musique]
en septembre 2019 elle débarque à l'onu
où elle fait son discours légendaire
marqué par cette fameuse tirade et song
achille barkin scoop people for you
stole my dreams
elle rend compte même donald trump
acquis et fait les gros yeux
bien que faisant figure de coqueluche et
une partie de la jeunesse mondiale
elle ne fait pas non plus l'unanimité il
faut dire que les contradictions dans
son discours ne manquent pas elle refuse
de prendre l'avion se déplace jusqu'au
forum de davos en train et traverse
l'atlantique sur un voilier le mali dia
le bateau est sponsorisé par la lgi
private banking qui appartient au groupe
financier suisse efg international
spécialisée dans la banque privée et la
gestion d'actifs
et aussi par le yacht club de monaco et
bmw qui en 2018 arrivé en 17e position
au classement des émissions polluantes
des voitures neuves vendues en 2018 par
les 20 plus gros constructeur en europe
niveau zéro carbone
il ya du boulot quand même et puis
rallier les états unis en voilier c'est
bien sauf que pour assurer l'intendance
l'entourage de greta dû prendre six
billets d'avion la rue puisque le bateau
faut le ramener
du coup cinq nouveaux membres d'équipage
se sont rendus à new york en avion pour
ramener le voilier
pendant que le capitaine boris herrmann
et rentrer en avion en europe donc en
vrai si greta et son père avaient pris
deux billets d'avion pour aller à new
york
ça aurait été moins polluants en fait
elle a ensuite posé sur twitter avec un
t-shirt antifa avant de faire marche
arrière parce que la violence c'est pas
bien l'année 2019 se termine pour elle
par le prix de personnalité de l'année
du times alors qu'on parlait même du
prix nobel de la paix pour greta
certains chefs d'état ne sont pas
tendres avec elle comme trump et ball
sonar ou tellement ridicule greta doit
travailler sur son problème de gestion
de la colère pu aller voir un bon vieux
film avec un ami détends toi greta
détends-toi vladimir poutine pour sa
part s'inquiètent d'une possible
manipulation de la jeune suédoise
les jeunes les adolescents réclame de la
tension au problème
brûlant d'aujourd'hui y compris les
problèmes écologiques c'est très bien et
bien sûr il faut les soutenir
mais quand quelqu'un utilise les enfants
les adolescents dans son propre intérêt
ça mérite d'être dénoncé et plus
récemment avec le co vide
elle a appelé ses sympathisants à
continuer le combat en respectant les
règles sanitaires et à faire la grève en
ligne à lui souhaite quand même une
bonne rentrée